[Music]
welcome today we're going to talk about
optimizing GCP security architecture for
maximum protection I just want to share
with you the agenda we're going to cover
the next 50 minutes we're gonna talk
about key risks and threats from an
enterprise perspective just to give you
a perspective of what we feel is facing
our clients today we're going to share
with you I view on what we think is a
Google Cloud Korea architecture model
and we'll share with you three
dimensions to that and then we thought
would be interesting to have a fireside
chat we've invited someone from Google
to join my colleague and I to go through
a Pfizer tried to try and guess the
questions that are in your head today
and then we're gonna end on a key
takeaway slide some of the key lessons
that we want to bring to today's session
so with that today's presenters my name
is Scheid Latif I'm a partner in PwC's
cloud security practice focused on
Google with me today will be joining
Gokul and Rob from from Google fun fat
by me I've done an 80-mile backpack in
New Mexico carrying 50 pounds over ten
days very tough and costs three large
mountains and really tested my stamina
enjoyed it a lot but why do you
introduce yourself good afternoon
everyone I'm Googler Grameen I'm a
director in our PwC is advisory group
focused on cloud transformation and
cloud security so fun fact I always
wanted to skydive but never really had
the guts to do it so I thought why don't
I do it in a safe environment and I
picked this one it turned out really fun
I really wanted to go back again but
that's something that I wanted to do so
let's talk about key risks and threats
to the cloud we thought we'd start with
a little bit of a privacy and regulatory
field to it and what we've done at PwC
is we've analyzed the market we've we've
looked at almost every single country in
the world and we've identified a number
of drivers environmental drivers
international law US law regulations
enforcement and case law and self
regulation and standards and you can see
some of the
examples on here and there's many more
what we find with our clients when we
talk to them they really don't have
enough insights because of the global
nature of them complexity of regulation
and sometimes it's important to
understand them so we've developed a
point of view in almost all these
countries and have it in a repository at
our fingertips we don't need to spend
hours and weeks researching it we have
it at our fingertips and then we think
that's an important attribute to begin
the cloud journey to really understand
that especially when you talk about data
localization and where data make
physical reside so what's the value
though of understanding all that
regulation what is there what's the
impact if you do if you have
non-compliance within this four broad
areas of non-compliance risks the first
is regulatory fines and penalties which
I'm sure most of you are aware of but
you might be subject to an FTC order
there's been a number of consumer breach
breaches have occurred that have
resulted in in decade Long's are
multiple decades of orders where you
have to do audits for the next 20 years
in some cases some business operations
might be limited so it could have a big
impact from a regulatory perspective
financial risk you could have loss of
revenue you could have litigation cost
which is often the case in some breaches
civil and criminal and penalties for
data breaches as well there's also an
reputation already and that's a big
discussion so many breach isn't it today
that have occurred some people have been
numb to it share prices don't really get
impacted much but does your reputation
get impacted in some cases they could
especially if you're a heavier line on
an online presence or heavily depend on
technology where security is really
paramount you might lose loss of
confidence in your employees and start
to get turnover and then finally
operational risk restricting operations
having the the ability in transferring
data in an appropriate way or having an
instant response program having sort of
remediation or obligations to the
interest response program that didn't
meet them so these are some of the
non-compliance regs that you have to be
careful of want to turn quickly to some
key considerations we try to summarize
this in a page which is very difficult
but we think these are like the main
themes
that we keep seeing over Nagar over
again at our clients governance and
keeping pace often cybersecurity is not
always as a seat at the table
when it comes to architectural
discussions IT may be at the front our
business might be at the front really do
I see sometimes cybers at the seat of
the table and with Google Cloud adoption
you have to be collaborating on that
solution together to make to enhance
enablement of agility through a dev up
environment and we'll talk later about
some thoughts around secure development
it's really important to bring that
mentality that cyber is an equal partner
in the discussion and in modernizing the
employee skill sets time and time again
we go to our clients we find there's not
enough resources that know this subject
and we get called upon to either augment
the team I'll bring our specialized
skill sets to the table I don't need the
access management you probably have
tended some of the sessions over the
last two days around this topic but when
you in a multi cloud environment is
quite complex to deal with and throw on
top of that legacy applications as well
so centralizing the addenda identity
both the user and device using MFA and
Pam at three really important topics to
address data protection and compliance I
mentioned earlier all the regulations
it's out there especially here since
we're all here in California today the
CCP Act is having a big impact and a lot
of my clients especially those with a
lot of consumer data they're having to
understand that where is data whose
access to it and how do they use it and
if I have to delete it how can I delete
it so it's really important to have an
effective program around them
legacy services what's the password data
migration from legacy apps to a workload
that's going into the cloud how do you
deal with data in transit how do you
encrypt it the right way and then
preservation response do you understand
the roles and responsibilities of the
cloud provider you might know that up
front
during early discussions but as you get
into month three months six months the
second year are you really clear and
what happens if there's a breach who's
responsible for what what are the SLA is
around that is really important to know
want to quickly top now jump into
something we've created at PwC
there's based on three basic principles
we we looked hard and we have a concept
called strategy through execution when
we deliver our solutions to a client so
when it came to Google cloud we said we
want to approach it in three dimensions
a technical architecture which is
probably a lot of what you saw it in in
this conference but we also feel it
strongly on a process architecture and
it controls architecture all three have
to come together and have to be linked
and that's what our view is around
bringing it all together into one place
so I'm going to share with you the next
few slides how we've approached this
topic the first ones controls was
relatively easy we've adopted NIST 853
we think that's the most comprehensive
framework out there especially in the
u.s. it's the the most stringent
baseline to go after we've coupled it
obviously with CSC is version 7 because
there's a lot of the technical hardening
standards that you would have we mapped
them both together created specific
controls for GCP and we've identified
which ones are really critical and
non-critical and we also related which
ones are really technically automated
possible through automation which
animals really process or workflow
orientated and which will rely on people
to follow we also took it one step
further and we worked out which ones are
really native to within GCP and which
ones are not often our clients want to
maximize as much as possible from google
cloud and what we've done is try to
identify that early up so having this
framework we have a baseline of which to
measure our adoption against so we think
this is one important attribute to have
a defined and you can see the categories
below I will go through them all you can
see them and present in front of you but
this illustrates the dimensions of
controls that you need to address it's
been a few Mis on this slide because
this is our technical architecture
underneath this we have content that
talks about what does good like from an
architectural perspective we don't want
to change too much of what's already in
there on premise walls but where we've
done it translated what does it mean to
being in the cloud so let me walk you
through how we would dress to this 10
o'clock Kotecha
first we use the NIST CSF domains
through identify protect detach
responder maneuver we feel that most of
our clients especially the board level
understand that terminology so we use
that lens to translate an executive
level here the different campaigns and
programs we're trying to do using those
domains how do we measure success we
measure success with through that lens
we also want to take in the count the
this technology stack of the cloud
environment so there's compute network
storage logging monitoring I am we look
at it from that lens and making sure we
address those components at the top we
also want to be aware of the security
risks these are inputs to each of our
technical requirements that we defined
visibility business awareness compliance
data security threat protection cloud I
am incident response vendor landscape
cloud dev ops vendor managed applied API
security and infrastructure security we
think it's important that our model
fully addresses those risks and they're
embedded in our technical architecture
so I'll walk you through them and then
I'm going to ask Gokul to share some
client experiences so for example I TS
imagine at a high level everyone knows
that inventory is important how do you
do that in a cloud when assets don't
last more than maybe a few hours or a
few weeks how do I get around that and
if I have to go back and investigate how
do I deal with that threat and rendering
bally management clients are struggling
sometimes in space how do you how do you
do a penetration test in GCP and how do
you do this on a regular basis what
tools are available for you to allow for
that data protection how do we make sure
that the data that's there in the cloud
is protected according to your policies
logging and monitoring it's really
important to define it so most of my
clients have a multiclad environment
what's the single source of truth when
it comes to the repository how do we
create a data lake that will give us the
visibility that we need and in a
real-time fashion instant response so if
you ever do have a breach of whatever
nature how do you respond quickly
business continuing disaster recovery
how do we make sure that you can recover
quickly we ourselves are actually in the
middle of researching some new ways of
looking at resiliency so we're looking
at new
actually leverage some of Google tech
right how do we quickly assess the
dependencies on different assets there
in the cloud governance and compliance
important part of our governance is who
owns cloud architecture who approves
cloud architecture when it comes to
service level approvals where do you get
that defined and now you get a blurring
between operations security and
development how do you bring all that
together in a defined way that doesn't
bring down your your levels of security
controls security development lifecycle
I'm you may be surprised to hear the
companies are struggling with adopting
in SDLC there's applicable to a cloud
like environment risk assurance imagine
how do you assure your customers your
third parties that you go to a safe
environment I am identity and access
management I've talked about already but
central theme how you control access
into the cloud awareness and training
and finally network security so I just
wanted to spend a little bit time
walking through each one but I'm gonna
ask Gokul now just just to share some
examples of some of our client
experiences as we've used this this
framework sure sure absolutely so I'm
going to take a couple of domains here
and then talk about specific customer
examples where we've been asked to come
in and help and that's resulted in our
developing this kind of a framework to
help out and future engagement so one of
the first things that we typically look
at is what does the customer have in
their cloud environment we recently were
brought in for a client who wanted to do
a very quick assessment on their
environment and look at their readiness
of their environment right the first
thing that we ask them is okay what are
you running on the cloud what are your
assets what are your resources a lot of
our clients have a little have an
inventory available which they can use
but a lot of the times that's not
accurate
right and in the cloud with the
scalability and the elasticity to it
there are resources up and going up and
down all the time so how do you how are
you going to have a framework and a
process in place to be able to measure
and track that or a consistent period of
time right so I think the key on the
Google side is GCP has already provided
some native
abilities like labeling they have the
security command center that's now
integrated with their asset lifecycle
that you can leverage to enable tagging
on your resources identifying what
resources and you build a very simple
schematic model which says here is my
resource here is what it's used who's
the owner what is the environment what
is the purpose of that and you have some
level of data classification associated
to that so once you have established
that model that then becomes your
baseline and you start slowly building
automation on top of that right so once
you have that automation it's very easy
to start building policies on top of
that and you start enforcing those
policies so the first thing that we
typically ask customer is what is your
asset inventory and I would recommend
you know looking at your policies and
your resource management lifecycle to
set up those labeling policies in place
another example that we commonly run
into when we walk into a customer is
traditionally you have these engineering
teams the security team then you have
the app development team doing separate
roles right as you go into the cloud
with all the automation and place those
lines have started blurring all the more
now right so you need a proper
methodology and a process in place to be
able to say how am I going to automate
my infrastructure how am I going to
provision my infrastructure how do I
embed security as part of my development
lifecycle right so somebody is running
containers or somebody else's having
traditional workloads how do I ensure a
consistent process that is baked in as
part of my build and release pipeline
right so that's another thing that we
commonly notice and we recommend coming
up with a proper process in place that
works not only on your on-prem
environment as well as on your cloud
environment and typically once you have
established the process that can be
tailored very quickly to any of the
cloud providers that you have so that's
a couple of examples that I had in mind
so at this point of time I would like to
invite Rob from Google to join us for a
quick fireside chat
thanks Copeland's thanks ahead so my
name is Rob Sadowski I work in the
product marketing organization here at
Google cloud on security and Trust and
my team really develops a lot of the
initial message when we engage with
customers around security helping to
educate them about what are the
capabilities that are inherent in our
platforms what are the different control
objectives that we can help them beat
how can we help them with key security
processes like security monitoring like
I am like you know those the core
disciplines of any security program I
guess in the spirit of sharing fun facts
one of the things that I like to do is I
see live music see concerts the concert
was great last night hopefully everyone
got to got to catch some of that seeing
a number of my favorite bands hundreds
of times so that's what I like to do if
I'm not doing security so cool so I
think that Rob but what we'll do is turn
to a fireside chat we try to think about
questions people in the audience might
be thinking of so why don't you start
and see where we go yeah I mean I think
the interesting thing is that you have
gone through these implementations with
many different types of clients and so
early on in those engagements just when
they're considering cloud whether
they're considering GCP I mean you
talked about technology you talked about
controls you talked about process where
are the where the biggest challenges
early on in the in the engagement or
early on in the process for people who
may be either starting that journey or
who are very early on in you know
considering this is actually an
interesting question because often we
get the inside look before even Google
gets to the door some of my largest
clients we get asked all the time is
this the right product is this the right
solution so before even a cloud provider
gets to the table we're asked does it
meet the security requirements and often
the ROI is quickly addressed that's not
an issue because why we're at the table
is this the right transformation process
absolutely but the fundamental question
that's always the biggest layer is it
meeting my security policies and often
what we find is that client security
policies are written in a way that
doesn't translate to
a google-like environment and so we're
having to translate their requirements
and then what they're trying to do to
what the platform is going to bring them
and some cases yes them might quite be
there but nine times out of ten there's
a translation required and so what we
have been asked to do more often not is
go in and try and understand that
complexity and bring simplicity because
that's the other side to equation bring
the simplicity and and understand what
the risks and the vulnerabilities but
more important the strengths that it
brings as well I mean you talked about
basing your work on frameworks like the
NIST framework whether it's CSF for some
of the control matrices I mean do you
see people basing their own policies
around some around domains like that or
do they tend to be they tend to be
looser so it has varied so I can give
you a story of a client fortune 15 so I
keep it within top 15 khawater which one
I showed up three years ago at this
client they created their policies on
input from legal input from operations
but proprietary bill which built up
their own thinking they asked me to come
in and evaluate not that but more their
posture overall and we concluded what
the most important thing was to do is to
actually base it on a recognized
framework there we use NIST CSF and more
often not we're finding NIST being the
most common framework to be used I so
still relevant especially from the
global side but the NIST is the most
relevant one yeah and I think that's one
of the reasons why at you know at Google
cloud we try to do or we commit to
getting certifications among the most
popular international frameworks and so
if someone is basing you know their set
of controls and how they how they meet
policy obligations based on something
like ISO 27001 or and then how that how
that gets translated through there's
often a direct mapping that they can use
to help them understand you know within
the confines of a shared responsibility
model what we're going to be doing what
they're going to be doing and then we
can also map out to two other controls
there two of the things that when I
mentioned there are the challenges with
our clients and the early adoption is do
I have the right technical competency to
it again a big percentage of our clients
at
building those resources out but there
they want to retool their current staff
to do it
which means they need a leader and a
change agent within the ranks to be able
to pull it through and more often not
sometimes they rely on a third party to
fill in that gap sometimes not always
but sometimes
but eventually they have to find that
that director that leader whoever it is
to really drive it to completion do you
find that that as organizations look to
look to do some of this that they are
looking to actually bring existing
control like what you know they have a
control objective what are they trying
to bring existing controls or are they
re looking at what is offered you know
in the cloud I think we're gonna talk
about some of this to say okay we can
replace this existing control that we
have in place you know it may be based
on a particular product of how they meet
that obligation with something cloud
native I think it's mentioned throughout
this conference transformation they want
to automate automation is like the key
to their success they don't want a
compliance order
they don't want controls they want to
automate which is a lot what we're going
to talk about later they want to
automate the process that's involved in
managing the environment they don't want
to have hands on they don't want people
involved they want to have machines
really do for them and some of the
companies we're dealing with the size
they do they have do they have a choice
of the scale and the manager they have
to deal with now it sounds good is that
possible today I think it is is it is it
done right now no everyone's trying to
get to that level right okay so maybe I
can ask you a question Bob just in
return we've heard a lot of exciting
announcements throughout the week I've
taught about some of the challenges but
what are the some of the things that
have taken your fancy from what you've
seen this week there really will help
clients out there today well that's a
it's a great segue shade because I think
you know you talked about transformation
and modernization of security controls
and capabilities I mean obviously what
we announced with Antos where there's a
lot of security capability that is built
in there whether it's a its
functionality like What's in is do you
know so you can create and monitor micro
services that you can ensure that you
have encryption between those different
services that you can automate
configurations and you know that was a
capability like configuration management
where you are able to define certain
policies instantiate those policies and
make sure those are pushed out at scale
and make sure things don't deviate it's
it's critically I think important as
part of especially as organizations
begin to scale to make sure that they're
adhering to policies that they're
following good governance and so forth
so I think that was one I think the
second you know go cool you you
mentioned cloud security command center
and I think that visibility into risk is
something that many organizations really
really have been focused on as they move
into the cloud how do I really
understand the risk profile of the
assets that are there so the fact that
now in this service you get a full
organization wide view of all your
assets and then can begin to look at the
risk profile of each of those different
assets and kind of what the some of the
other capabilities where we brought on
something like security health analytics
where we can say for those assets are
they configured in such a way that is
creating inordinate level of risk like
do we have storage buckets with you know
broad permissions that may be open to
the internet do we have overly
permissive firewall rules do we have
things that again would put me in a
situation where I would not be able to
meet the objective of the given policy
and I think back to the automation point
you know something we talked about in
terms of event threat detection how can
we help automate or at least provide
some of the labor in the detection
process so taking being able to take the
logs and I think we're going to talk
about logging in and monitoring here in
a minute being able to take that and
actually use intelligence that we've
gathered to give you a sense of are
there particular malicious events or
signs of compromise that you need to
look for and I think the the the final
or you know a couple others I think
around identity you know I think that in
terms of good governance and
implementing policies identity is still
one of the biggest control points that
we have in cloud that where we may not
be able to implement some of the
controls that we want we have wanted
them to in terms of the network because
services are moving up the stack that
we're looking you know less and less at
layer 3
four and more and more at layer seven
that how can we how can really you know
get those get that level of control in
the environment and knowing who's in the
environment being able to manage that
access appropriately throughout its
lifecycle and right at the beginning of
that it's authentication so the fact
that we introduced the kind of Android
being able to use the Android phone as a
security key establishing that route
that route trusted identity at the at
the beginning I think is really really
important so those those are a few that
stood out especially within the context
of what we are what we're doing here in
terms of being able to implement strong
controls and strong governance across
the platform and really see how
effective those are and one thing that
stood out to me in addition to what
you've just said it's a training aspect
I'm glad to see there's a security
certification now eventually out because
I think that's absolutely needed out
there yeah I mean if folks didn't see
that basically the week before we talked
to we introduced a specific security
certification for GCP and there's a set
of course work that you can go and get
that specialization and so I think and a
lot of that is driven by demands that we
have had you know we we want to have
more education about the different
security capabilities and how they might
be applied and so that's a really strong
I think start as you begin to delve more
deeply into these issues great so going
back to you shed and and Gokul you know
when when you know you've gotten to the
part of advisory where people have
decided to get into cloud and they are
saying okay we have this workload we
have this type of data what are that
what are they actually looking to get
you know in terms of payoff right is it
security I mean there's this there's
this belief I think that has evolved
over time that moving to the cloud can
actually make you more potentially
increase your security posture or allow
you to implement stronger or better
governance is that part of it or is it
is it still something else so there are
a number of drivers and I think it
varies according to industry you're in a
quote and also the type of company you
are in terms of your style of management
but more often not ROI is one of the
first drivers out there and often it's a
data center rationalization issue some
of my clients have recognized maintain
your data center today is really
expensive not to mention I got to make
it secure so that drives them to a
conclusion I got to move more things
into the cloud and then the question
becomes what workloads connect but
they're over the years it's been very
slow but I see now I worked with a
FinTech client just recently they move
the entire production and all the entire
platform into Google Cloud and and went
live and so those things are changing
but I still there's some still a bigger
majority of clients than of yet not yet
adopted cloud so I think there's huge
growth potential still so absolutely ry
but the other thing is transformation
they're they're eager to leverage some
of the MI and the artificial
intelligence capability within compute
to really honnest business
transformation that even more than
agility is driving some of the adoption
and those use cases are driving the
transformation that which driving our
business as well yeah so let me push on
that on that point a little bit I mean
do you see clients who feel that moving
to the cloud either you know enhances
their security posture or allows them to
have stronger more effective governance
a personal view rather than a firm view
just because I don't want to say too
much on the firm half but I personally
believe that from my experience and I've
been in in security consulting over 30
years that going to a reputable cloud
solution such as Google is actually more
beneficial than trying to build it
yourself and when you think about the
complexities of an emerging tech that's
about to hit us you need to be with a
provider that can give this you that
capability so Rob how does Google
initially at the beginning when you're
adopting cloud Google cloud how do you
help in those initial stages in creating
those business cases and how do you help
to meet their internal choirs especially
on the first few months when they're
getting off the ground yeah I mean I
think that that's a nice segue right
because one of the things that we that
we try to do is is show that level of
security enhancement or security benefit
so tip you know typically what would
happen very early on we understand what
are the different types of sir
what is the workload or what is the what
is the application and from there we
understand a little bit more about the
business process we understand a little
bit more about the type of data and then
what we want to do back to kind of what
you were saying and why I was asking
about that is understand what are the
security policies that are around that
data and where it gets challenging in
some cases that if the policy isn't
particularly well defined right or if
there aren't stated control objectives
because what we like to then do is be
able to give an overview or give a sense
of okay here's how you can use the
features in the platform to protect this
right here's how you can meet your
obligations from an internal policy or
also from potentially an external and
regulatory perspective or in the ways
that we can help right and that's where
we talk about the relevant
certifications or the relevant
documentation we have around some of
those different things another so we
really like to have the security
conversation up front because we know
that it becomes harder and harder to
drive change if there are questions
about risk there if there are questions
about you know being able to meet
obligations and guidance and so forth so
I think that that's a that's a big part
of it another things that we like to do
early on in the in the engagement is to
even go far as to do workshops and that
may be you know with with partners like
yourselves or internally with our folks
where again we look at internal policies
we interview stakeholders we understand
security objectives we do some
assessment of existing controls because
sometimes you know the the Aza's
environment doesn't match the desired
future state and so we can do a little
bit of solutioning and designing ahead
of time and then kind of come up with a
roadmap as to some of the things that
are must implements and then and then
phase for other pieces so that's what we
try to do early on but clearly security
has to be an integrated part of that of
that design decision I mean just like
the the philosophy of you know when we
are doing CI CD of shifting security
left-right it's it's it's shifting
security left in the engagement itself
so we are we are planning and not saying
oh now we have this workload weight you
know how are we gonna meet the meet the
obligations that we have do you find who
is most engaged in party when you go to
a client which function security IT
business
that you feel most closest I talk it has
to be all the above but I I mean I think
that what we see the most is the the the
security function is seen as the as the
the team or the the center that is gonna
sign off on a lot of what happens so
that's where a lot of the gravity is but
again in doing interviews and
understanding that we have to understand
from the business side and from other
parts who have influence over it because
everyone needs to be bought in I don't
know how familiar you are with the
three-day discovery programs I just
recently found out bet that you actually
spend three days with a client and
actually do workshops and educate the
minds creator if you want to talk a
little bit about that yeah I mean again
it's a it's a kind of work shopping
process where we can do some education
about the controls and contextualize it
in terms of the existing business okay
so again getting more to the specific
controls and to end technologies what
are the what are the biggest challenge
in terms of the technical side you know
what is specific security controls or
pieces of functionality are they looking
to implement and are they challenged to
implement so DLP was one and that just
recently got embedded into the roadmap
within there but again when my clients
was challenged it wasn't available at
the time but now it is but DLP's was one
challenge and that's really important
when you deal with privacy matters sim
and you BA um so with insider threat M
for detection newbie is really important
use B of analytics and how do you use an
existing sim platform using stat driver
or the security command center had I use
that with their existing platform that
might have container security and
obviously anthos is a great example of
bringing a multi cloud feature to it but
managing your operations around the new
technology that brings will be
interesting an endpoint detection and
response that's a challenge for most
clients even on on-premise how do you do
it in the virtual environment and how do
you get real-time indications of what's
going on in that space
firewall real processes changes made to
firewalls when you're in a developer
environment are made very quickly but
may not be done right one of my other
clients that I work with
they changed their firewalls really
quickly to the point where I created
problems because they're in a dev
environment making quickly so how do you
create controls around changes which
sounds obvious but I'm talking about a
live example that that wasn't the case
and then configuration management that's
the other one
with so many configurations the ability
to make so many changes how do you
manage that can that be scripted can we
control that yeah I mean I think that I
think they clearly the the the rapidity
which you know the ease of making
changes allows it you know which is
great because it allows you to be
responsive but it also can cause
configuration drift and other things
like that so we try to and that's a
technology side thing and it's also a
process side thing but it's certainly
not something to be underestimated and I
think we we see that as well so maybe
what are the native solutions within GCP
that you think can address some of the
things I just brought up yeah I mean I
mean clearly we have a lot of controls
that can address many of those different
types of things you talk about
behavioral analysis and things like that
one of the things we talked about this
week was our policy intelligence tool
that that we're bringing out and so one
of the things that we're doing there is
looking at the set of iam roles that
have been defined and then looking at
access that's happening and being able
to say is there a mismatch even if a
role is defined correctly we can say
these you this group of users have not
accessed this resource should we remove
this permission so you know getting to
more effective governance based on user
behavior and looking at that over time I
think you you know as you mentioned
container security there are a number of
capabilities we talked about we talked
this week about what we are doing around
container registry vulnerability
scanning so being able to scan for
vulnerabilities in the development
process and provide at a stations of
whether particular components or other
underlying things have vulnerabilities
in them and then very much related to
that is a tool that is now GA called
binary authorization so in that process
making sure that code is signed and
checked through based on a variety of
criteria before it actually goes to the
Lucas to the deploy state so this whole
idea of giving you tooling to
control and get oversight over your
software supply chain is critically
important as organizations gonna
transform and modernize some of these
dev processes and those those are two
you know capabilities that are that are
kind of built in there so let's take a
pause from it because Gokul has been
quiet on the end and want to bring him
in so I want a deep dive a little bit
more into identity access management
because I think it's a core capability
that needs to be really thought through
maybe Gokul I'm gonna share a slide that
you can maybe illustrate tell us a
little bit more about what you need to
have to have an effective I am an
initiative so so I am as one of the core
tenets of when we go into a customer in
site and they want to build out their
cloud transformation program I am is one
of the core foundational capabilities
that we start with right so if if you
don't get the I am in the resource
hierarchy right then it causes a bigger
challenge as you start scaling up your
business so some of the basic tenants as
we look at I am as how do you organize
your resources in Google what are the
different capability services that are
available out of the box what
considerations you need to be thinking
about when you as you organize your
projects and your folder structure in
your resource structure in your Google
environment is the first thing that we
look at so what do I mean by that Google
has a resource hierarchy which starts
with organization resource and then
there's folders and then there's
projects and then there's resource
underlying resources compute your
network all those resources so so
typically when we go in and at the root
level organization is the node that
customers typically start with right and
if you are a G suite up if you have a G
suite account or on a cloud identity
account that organization resources
available to you the advantage of that
resources you can now start tying your
policies and your controls at the
organizational level right you don't in
some cases is actually beneficial you
don't have to duplicate them across
multiple projects so that's the root
level that you get and and typically if
if you once you start that organization
level any projects that you create or
then automatically associated to that
domain and
then as part of that associated to your
organization so if somebody leaves your
organization you already have that
associated to your organization it
follows the organization and not the
individual who's actually leaving the
organization right so from an
administrator perspective its
centralized management it allows you to
manage your resources and your controls
and the policies in a centralized manner
so that's why having that organizational
resource helps you set the precedence so
then we have this concept of folders
resources right so a lot of times our
customers want to segregate their
projects by functional units by
departments by environment so that's
where the concept of folders is very
helpful so I'm gonna have a marketing
department I might have another legal
department I don't
I want specific policies associated to
that I'm on projects which have specific
controls
I am policies related only for that
particular department right so that's
where I use the concept of folders to
group similar functional units or
similar functions together as part of
the folder structure then you have the
actual project which which derives from
the folder right and folder is an
optional level you don't have to need I
have that folder structure but we
typically recommend that if you want to
bunch or group together similar
functional units at the project level
that's where the real work actually
happens that's when you stand up your
resources you spin up your applications
that's where you deploy everything right
so the project is the primary control
that you have now once you have set up
this organizational structure in place
typically our customers say so know what
is a recommended project structure that
I need to have do I need to have it by
environment do I need to have it by
Department again typical answer is it
depends right so if you are an
organization unless you have very
specific requirements that say one so
let's say I have an organization and
there is another organization which has
completely different set of policies and
functions and I want complete isolation
that's when you'll really need two
separate organizations otherwise one
organization is the way to go one
is the way to go and then from a project
level that's where you start segregating
projects so I could have projects
created for dev environment for my QA or
my production environment or I could
also slice it in different ways say I
need my project structure to be set up
by my functional units by marketing you
have a certain set of project hierarchy
you have certain users roles policies
assigned by that functional unit so
that's the way that we typically look at
so once you get that right then you
start thinking about the concept of
identity and roles right so really there
is two kinds of identity in GCP one is
the user end in D and then there is the
service account identity right so users
are pretty much all your users the
individual users who are going to be
using the environment so that's
straightforward these service accounts
are slightly tricky so they are
typically used if you want to perform an
operation on behalf of another user on
behalf of an application that's when
service accounts are typically used you
can use it as an identity as well as a
resource right so what I mean by that is
so let's say I want to have some kind of
a notification or an automated job that
is one of I wanna be running in the
background I don't want to be running it
as an individual user that's when the
concept of service account actually
applies so it it's very critical at a
high level when you before you start
moving all your workloads to the cloud
or before you set up your workloads on
the cloud to ensure that you have the
iam structure built our do you have your
users roles and policies that are
clearly mapped out and then you start
you know migrating your data and set up
your projects in place so Rob anything
specific from an identity perspective
that Google is working on any of the
well I think that I think you give a
good overview here I think one thing
that I talked about in terms of policy
intelligence I talked a little bit about
making recommendations there's also a
complimentary piece called access
troubleshooter that so as you set up
roles and as you set up permissions if
something isn't able to be accessed
troubleshooter can help you walk through
and figure out exactly why so you don't
wind up saying just you know grant all
privileges right so you can continue to
adhere
to those particular to those particular
things and then we made a number of
other announcements around our own cloud
identity where a lot of times we set up
those accounts or the ability to use
Active Directory and use that as a
managed service so those were a couple
of couple of things but I think
especially in terms of what we're doing
around policy intelligence helping you
get those permissions and helping you
make sure that you are continuing to
enforce things like lease privilege
effectively across multiple things users
already set up but a lot of times
they're not even using those roles so
the idea is to have fine-grained roles
and policies associated to that we
typically a lot of our clients start
with the traditional primitive roles
which are no longer recommended right so
then you have the predefined roles which
are which gives you those bunching of
those policies which is good but really
the custom roles is where you get the
full power of Google right you will be
able to automate what exactly what
permissions set a particular user is
required to use right with this new
implementation that Google has come out
with you already have a weight that
Google is going to tell you hey you have
this user you have assigned these
permissions but it's not required you're
not using them so start taking it back
right so that's very helpful so yeah I
mean I think the other analog shed is so
now we understand you know and are
trying to gain control over those users
but we also have to audit that activity
and so monitoring and logging is
something you know you referred to at
the beginning what are your kind of best
practices or thinking around that as you
work with clients around monitoring
logging and being able to provide that
that documentation absolutely so
traditionally all of our customers have
some kind of a logging and monitoring
solution on Prem rides and so they they
want to leverage the same solution as
they go to the cloud as well and a lot
of times that will work right but by by
default Google already provides you
capabilities like stackdriver which will
let you look at the logs the logs are
automatically enabled they are
automatically stored and stackdriver and
you have a way to collect it X
faltered and then do some analytics on
top of it right so at the base
infrastructure layer level you already
have tools like stackdriver which will
let you do that then you'll need to
start looking at what kind of
application level logs and monitoring
that I'll have to manage and then
finally you'll look at from a business
transparency perspective what are the
business metrics and the logs that I
need to be starting to collect right so
those are the three levels that I would
typically start looking at the the other
good thing in Google is and I know you
can talk a little bit about the access
transparency but really when we go to a
customer and it goes back to how we
structure our projects so typically we
would have a security SEC ops
engineering team which is focused on
primarily looking at the audit events
looking at the security events that are
happening so the way that you structure
your projects again is very critical so
you would have your engineering teams
focus on a separate project structure
all your security logging in all those
logs will be managed in a separate
project and only your security
engineering team gets access to that
right so there is clear separation of
duties you have a way to monitor who
gets access to the logs and you can
report it on if you know as if there is
unauthorized access to the logs again
some of the things that we have seen as
best practices go with fine-grained
rules give absolutely minimum
permissions start with the editor role
because editor is required in a lot of
cases for you to be able to manage the
logs and do some kind of an
instrumentation from the logs so start
there and then you know expand from
those capabilities by default also
another question that comes up as our
customers ask I store all these logs or
these logs encrypted are they stored in
a safe manner by default when they are
stored in your cloud storage buckets
they are all encrypted by default you
have a way to actually use your secret
management capabilities to manage access
to those logs so those are some of the
high-level best practices that we
recommend as we look at logging and
monitoring as we work with our clients
do you want to talk a little bit about
yeah I mean I think that just one thing
you talked about separation of logs by
project and being able to get that
granularity I think everyone is if
you're not aware they're actually when
we think about cloud audit logging 3
just
set of logs there are Advent activity
logs which allow you see what
administrators are doing there's kind of
a system event logs which you know if
you're starting something on compute
engine what are the different things
like if a live migration happens when
did that happen for example there are
also data access logs so you can see not
only from an administrative perspective
but also from a user perspective people
who have roles and permissions when that
data is it has been accessed so that
night there's a nice real separation
between those so depending on what
you're looking for and what you are
going to have to provide documentation
on the different types of logs can
support that and then we also augment
that and you know that's for your own
users and your own administrators but we
augment that with access transparency
logs so this is an optional feature that
you can turn on which allows you to see
if Google support engineers or
administrators are accessing any of your
data so that you know helps with the
overall understanding of what's
happening in my environment you know
being able to provide a full log of our
new full log of access of that and so
that kind of complements that piece and
another thing we talked about you know
that many organizations have existing
log management systems and capabilities
things like like a Splunk or other
systems like that in cloud security
command center we've actually Allah put
added capabilities in the in the ga
release to support direct connection to
that with this what this plumb connector
so that's where you're doing some of the
reporting and auditing you can get
events from there so yeah I mean clearly
an area that we've focused so maybe to
wrap this up you know are there specific
tools or frameworks or other things that
you use specifically with with your
clients in driving through some of these
issues
sure I've just summarized them here
quickly on the slide to speed up our
discussion so as I mentioned before and
we gave a very highly representation the
earlier slides but we created a
architectural blueprint we've actually
worked with clients where they've asked
us tell us what good looks like from an
architectural perspective so we already
have pre-designed templates around what
architecture should look like
we then tailor that to the needs of the
client and that's been a huge success
for us in trying to accelerate the
program and that again process controls
and technology we look at all three
elements we also make sure that the
controls that we
I distinguish between what's available
in Google and what's not and that's
really important to know because we've
also developed a understanding of the
vendor ecosystem a lot of our clients
say where is the best tool to use what's
the right thing to use here we developed
a point of view on that we've developed
a selection of criteria against
different functions and then a hobby
ball analysis around that and developed
a portfolio it's hard to keep up because
there's a lot of new to third party
products on the market but we've got
that as well at our disposal the other
thing we have is we've developed a tool
because often we can put a tool that's
already available but it takes time to
put that there so we developed some
scripts of our own based again on
benchmarks that are available in the
industry C is family and we run our
scripts and quickly find out whether
things are hardened right way in the VM
level and then finally best practices
we've created a live because we've been
to a few clients now we've captured best
practices so we'd have to repeat the
best practices it's hard to keep up with
all the changes that going on with
Google but as we do we keep updating for
that as well so we're almost done here
you know Google or or shed you know if
you had to make you know a couple of key
takeaways or recommendations around
around this and architecting about what
what would they be I think it's these
four or five basic things understand
your regulatory environment and then
send it well what does that really mean
for you assess the key risks I didn't
touch about threat modeling but frame
modeling is essential to understand what
the new tack services that the cloud can
bring to you once you understand those
things you've got the base lines of
understanding start to implement the
right architecture use pre-tested
architectural blueprints don't make it
up and then identify the third-party
solutions to augment your security go
cloud does provide a lot but doesn't
provide everything so make sure you have
that and fight and then have monitor and
audit directly addressed if you dress
these you're walling away to a secure
cloud all right great
well thank you all for for coming and
listening and our dialogue and thank our
panelists and have a good rest of next
not too much left
[Applause]
[Music]